Would you say Denver's the best comedy town in the country.
It's up there.
I fucking love it there.
I'm going there in August.
I'm doing that place again.
I fucking love it.
Yeah.
It's one of my favorite places on the planet period.
Like if I was going to leave la,
Denver's one of the spots that I would pick.
I think about like when I mentioned the leave,
where would I go and Denver's a Denver's at the top of the list.
I used to want to go to like Seattle or Portland and then I read that article,
that terrifying article about how like not just like if we talks about the big
one earthquake in La and they're like,
what's really going to fuck shit up is the tsunami that's going to happen on
that bought line.
They're like,
Portland and Seattle are going to be gone.
When that tsunami 100% right?
100% yeah.
It's just whether it's a hundred years from now or two [inaudible] Jesus.
If we wake up one day in Seattle's gone,
13 million people dead.
It goes deep into Washington state all the way to Tacoma.
The ocean goes to Tacoma.
Oh,
that there was an article that they like talked about like what?
How,
what would happen?
Like what would happen like minute by minute in Portland with this,
with this going on.
It was just terrifying.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
Too risky.
Also seasonal depression is real.
Oh,
for sure.
I have a buddy of mine who moved to,
um,
he moved to Portland and started Jujitsu school out there and I was like,
do you like it?
He was like,
dude,
I fucking love it.
I go,
you don't Miss La at all.
He was like,
no.
I go,
what about the range of Bobby?
I was like,
no,
no.
It's nothing.
Two years later,
he's back in La.
I go,
what happened?
He goes to fucking weather.
I go,
you liar.
I,
you would try to convince me.
You would try to tell me.
And he started laughing.
He's like convincing myself.
Yeah,
he be,
he bought into it.
He goes,
I go.
What happened is I came back one time and when it was rainy out there and it
wasn't rainy here and I was like,
what am I doing?
I go,
I'm less happy there.